now the jailed u.s hacktivist martin
gottesfeld is back in the spotlight he
is serving time for carrying out a cyber
attack on a hospital which he claims had
mistreated a teenage girl it is a case
we've been following very closely and
now there are concerns for his own
treatment and health behind bars
[Music]
well gotta spell's wife donna claims he
is currently on hunger strike and in
solitary confinement and says she hasn't
heard from him for about a week earlier
she spoke to my colleague colin bray
the last time anyone has heard from him
is september 23rd
um and when he
is put in
in solitary it usually or it almost
always comes with a hunger strike
and the conditions are so deplorable
from
water that
drinking water that corrodes metal
to hot steam pipes it's very dangerous
that place is so scary i spoke to a
lawyer the other week that told me that
it's the worst prison in the united
states
and the shoe is different than even the
shoe that they use for the rest of the
facility it's it's really scary if you
say that martin's been stripped of his
phone and that was shortly after your
last uh conversation uh why was that is
it just a temporary punishment were you
warned that communicating with us here
at rt could violate prison rules we
believe that it's retaliatory uh
for
speaking out against the prison rape
elimination act violations from the unit
manager there's not an iota of evidence
that he's done anything wrong
nor can they provide any it doesn't seem
to matter though because they've already
thrown him in the shoe um i don't know
the extent of the punishment whether
that's includes more or how much time
this is going to take
well as we heard there all that
apparently happened after donna
cottisfeld gave a recording of a
conversation with her husband to rt
early this month in it he talked about
alleged judicial corruption and says
that he does not regret a thing
but i'm certainly not not going to quiet
now
continue to be very loud and to expose
all the corruption that's going on
there's a lot of it what happened to her
she's going to have some atrocity
unacceptable
and no system should be put in the
position that i was in
to have to make the decisions that i had
to make
well we have asked the prison to comment
on this although so far they have not
replied now goddessfeld was jailed back
in 2018 over his fight for what he
believed was right
[Music]
please let me go home right now i need
to be home with my family
[Music]
she has been totally medically abused
finally
common sense prevailed
[Music]
i just don't know how this really
happened because it doesn't feel like
it's it's real it feels so good to be
home
[Music]
now in further allegations he also says
that he was sexually abused by a unit
manager in prison and that his
complaints were ignored again the
facility hasn't commented on those
claims but this is what his wife told us
the man in question is the unit manager
for the cmu as well as for death row he
has sexually abused a number of inmates
in marty's case
he looked at him while he was in the
nude and defecating as he's done with
other people he stuck his hand into
occupied showers um
he's gone into cells unescorted and off
camera
um in a display i guess of dominance and
sexual intimidation a ton of rules on
the books about um priya and that's the
prison rape elimination act and how the
people that accuse others are supposed
to be protected and have investigations
and none of that has happened
you